what spiritual advice would you tell
someone who's entering the competitive
world of movies other media you know
when it comes down so much too if
there's name talent in a project or what
someone looks like I think we all get
caught up in another level of thinking
that's very superficial and competitive
so how do we see true to ourselves and
not end up playing the game so to speak
that's a really good question because it
is in this business that I'm still new
to there's a lot of temptation to go for
the big names and the stars and you know
this person is more important in the
project and that but the key for me is
just the same theme of the movie is
still going back into the heart of what
inspired me as a creative person to do
this project in the first place which
was a desire to share and to be offering
real powerful transformative solutions
from people because it's not about the
fame that I did this film you know I I
just you know I'm a mom of four and I
you know have my my life and I like to
work and help people through transition
but it's about the passion that I have
to help other people to be of service
and then in that from that place of
heart every single person in this film
is just as important as everybody else I
have some beautiful people like
grandmother margarita of the seven
grandmother's the of the healing
traditions who's on camera for a
probably a total of thirty seconds and
she's just as important to me as a
filmmaker as some people who have the
bigger name recognition it's always
about staying in the heart so many
people have advice to tell me do this
and market this person over that so
everybody is important and the vision is
about compassion and healing and that's
the way that I stay grounded in the
creative aspect of the project
you